[Music]
it was clear from the number of people
exercising and jogging by the river
saying in paris
that people were making the most of
being allowed outside
the governments imposed a third lockdown
on the city and 15 regions
but this time people aren't required to
stay indoors all day
we have to work all week so thankfully
we can go outside it's a necessity it
helps moral to be able to share some
good moments
we need to adapt again which will be
painful in the days to come but we have
to get on with it and hope it gets
better
in other parts of paris a more familiar
lockdown site
quiet streets clothes shops and
businesses although schools and
essential stores can stay
open
shopkeepers and small business owners
are at the point of exhaustion
after more than a year of yellow vests
strikes
now three lockdowns in some regions it's
too much
covert cases are rising in france with
almost
40 000 new infections a day intensive
care units in paris hospitals
are full so some patients are being
transferred elsewhere
french government says the parts of
france are battling
a third wave they hope that the regional
restrictions
will help avoid another national
lockdown
by helping to stop the spread of the
virus and winning time for more people
to be vaccinated
on friday the french prime minister
jacques dex received an
astrazeneca jab an attempt to convince
the public of its safety
after months of negative publicity and a
temporary suspension
vaccine skepticism is high in france but
at this immunization center
the cues were long i'm fine with the
astrazeneca but it's normal that some
people are worried because of the recent
events
but i think confidence will return in
the coming weeks
for some doctors the restrictions aren't
tight enough but
french president emmanuel macron says
the economy and people's mental health
must
also be considered for now the new
lockdown is said to last one
month however many people suspect it
could run much longer
natasha butler al jazeera paris